Kerry Washington she was the toast of
another big celebration last night but
the scandal star was still basking and
that met afterglow surprising big last
night I saw my husband jumping into
selfish that doesn't usually happen that
was very surprising Kerry Slade again in
this dramatic black-and-white Carolina
Herrera gown at the Bronx Children's
Museum event where the Bronx native was
being honored she told us she's fond
memories of growing up in the borough
Jennifer Lopez was my dance teacher
Jennifer was one of the big girls I
remember when she left to walk to LA to
try to make it big and that obviously
left a big impression on me another
a-lister who made an impression on
Carrie back in the day Gwyneth Paltrow
they went to high school together
Carrie joined the school's acapella club
because Gwyneth was president but the
biggest influence on miss Washington
clearly her parents Gary's mom is on the
board of the museum and presented her
with the imagination award they always
know best I was like oh I'll hold the
award my mother's like it's gonna fly it
I'm like it's fine she's like it's not
fine this is really a passion project of
my mother she has spent her entire life
working to improve lives for children in
the Bronx myself included the scandal
star auctioned off the set visit to her
Shonda Rimes hound show to benefit the
museum and she told us the season finale
on May 18 is full of surprises nobody
gets what they want
when we shot the final scene for the
last episode of the season
I had goosebumps I never saw it coming
and I'm crazy excited about next season
Olivia will get her happy ending but
that depends on how Shonda defines happy
do you really think she's gonna get the
happy ending is my question ever no at
that shot
they always shock you they say they're
going to and then they shock they blow
your mind
[Music]